tengo 24 soy estudiantes de derecho yo
soy presidente de la federación de
estudiante en la universidad de chile
fui la primera mujer trans en ocupar ese
cargo
emilia sneijder es uno de los casi 1.300
candidatos en chile para conformar la
convención constituyente la misión de
los 155 que resulten elegidos será poner
fin en el país a una de las más robustas
herencias de la dictadura su actual
constitución
desde esa experiencia de hacer grupos
históricamente excluidos de la política
las personas trans las mujeres los
movimientos sociales podemos aportar a
repensar la democracia en chile para
construir una mejor democracia más
profunda más directa más deliberativa
paritaria como el preso constituyente
que vamos a tener en chile que el
primero barita compañía en el mundo post
era del movimiento feminista en chile
que se tomó las universidades y los
titulares del mundo en 2018 la lucha de
emilia visibiliza también la realidad
trans en un chile aún muy conservador en
ciertos sectores sociales queremos darle
a toda la discusión constitucional una
perspectiva feminista y desde las
disidencias sexuales no poner a algunos
artículos sino tener una perspectiva
transversal desde allí
tras la suspensión de las elecciones
previstas para el 11 de abril pasado sin
apoyo económico de grupos poderosos su
mayor fortaleza está en conquistar la
calle puerta a puerta y en su bagaje
como líder social presente en múltiples
luchas chile- nuevamente se queda abajo
y garantizado el derecho que es
fundamental
a niños y adolescentes que la educación
sexual integral emilia quema los últimos
cartuchos para tratar de convertirse en
una de las voces que haga historia al
dejar atrás la constitución de 1980 uno
de los últimos legados del dictador
augusto pinochet y construir un nuevo
mapa de ruta para un chile más justo
digno e igualitario tenemos que seguir
hablando traficando esos saberes que no
han llegado de una sexualidad libre
disidente de lo que todas las cosas que
no buscan a nosotros